public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
cette semaine bonjour laurent berger
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
à la tête du premier syndicat de france
et nous sommes ensemble pendant 45
minutes pour vous interroger à mes côtés
cette semaine nos deux partenaires faire
l'autre côté journaliste à radio
classique et paul briat journalistes à
l'aef et bonjour à tous les deux jours
et durant cette émission laurent berger
vous répondrez à trois grandes questions
une première partie sur la politique
migratoire du gouvernement yat il trop
de fermeté et pas assez
d'humanité en deuxième partie nous nous
intéresserons à vos rapports avec
l'exécutif pourquoi le courant ne passe
pas entre vous et emmanuel macron et
puis enfin nous parlerons des nombreuses
réformes du gouvernement ces réformes
menace-t-elle le modèle social français
ce sera le thème de notre troisième
partie et on commence tout de suite avec
les questions d'actualité
[Musique]
on va commencer avec la politique
migratoire à laurent berger le
gouvernement a dévoilé les grandes
lignes de son futur projet de loi
immigration asile réduction des délais
de traitement des demandes d'asile
allongement de la durée légale de
rétention dans les centres selon vous y
at il trop de fermeté et pas assez
d'humanité oui il n'ya pas assez
d'humanité c'est clair n'a pas assez
d'humanité moi je suis d'accord sur le
premier volet c'est à dire renforcer la
politique d'asile aller plus vite dans
le d day pour instruire les dossiers
mais je suis en désaccord avec cette
politique inhumaine qui est tracé
concernant les réfugiés qui fuient les
pays parce qu'ils sont en guerre parce
qu'ils ont des difficultés économiques
des difficultés climatiques et je crois
moi j'appelle en tout cas de j'exhorte
le gouvernement je les fais dès lundi à
revenir sur cette politique et à avoir
une vraie politique qui serait en deux
temps d'abord hormis les réfugiés la
politique d'asile âgé dé j'étais
d'accord une vraie politique nouvelle
réflexion sur la politique migratoire au
niveau européen ça veut dire quoi de
faire évoluer les règles par exemple et
deuxièmement un devoir d'humanité un
devoir d'accueil des personnes qui sont
persécutés et qui soe qui fuient des
pays où ils ne peuvent pas vivre
dignement et je crois que si on a vu des
images qui sont totalement choquant vous
devriez humaine c'est très fort comme
comme où c'est la réalité de ce qu'on a
vu et je crois que ce titre de président
de la république n'assume pas les
promesses qu'il avait fait et dans
d'autres registres et il a raison parce
que c'est des promesses c'est fait pour
être mises en oeuvre et sur ce point là
c'est pas assumer c'est parce qu'ils
avaient été promis et pendant la
campagne présidentielle c'est ce que
fait le président macron oui je le
constate comme tout le monde et où s'est
il ya un il y à des mesures enfin on
peut mesurer assez facilement le degré
d'indignation sur ce dossier là en
regardant ce que disent des associations
qui travaillent avec les migrants quand
on a des personnes comme je vienne
geneviève jacques de la cimade qui vient
de faire une vidéo sur twitter où elle
interpelle le président de la république
et qui avec beaucoup de dignité dit
combien cette politique est inhumaine
quand le secours catholique qu'en france
terre d'asile et d'autres encore disent
qu'il ya un problème il faut qu'il faut
écouter il faut écouter aujourd'hui moi
je le dis je j'ai mal aux valeurs de mon
pays dans la politique migratoire
quémener vous est en colère monsieur
bergé je suis indigné je suis indigné
parce que on peut discuter de tout un
tas de curseur sur un certain nombre de
dossiers on y reviendra et puis voilà
mais il ya des choses sur les valeurs
sur lesquelles on revient pas notre pays
mais que le grattoir que veut mettre en
en actions le gouvernement de la france
je crois qu'elle remet en cause un droit
et un devoir fondamental qui est
l'accueil dans la dignité des personnes
persécutées et des migrants je crois
qu'elle remet ça en cause et c'est pour
moi inacceptable c'est même choquant
vous avez parlé de des associations de
leur réaction s'est essentiellement par
rapport à cette circulaire du 12
décembre le ministère de l'intérieur a
envoyé au préfet ils montrent qu'ils
envoient des équipes mobiles pour
procéder à un recensement dans les
centres dans les foyers d'accueil
beauvau parle de mesures pratiques les
associations comme vous l'avez dit récul
ça elle demande le retrait de la
circulaire et vous oui je demande le
retrait de la circulaire avec ces
associations je lui ai demandé dès lundi
j'ai fait savoir au gouvernement
l'indignation de la cfdt sur ce sujet là
et je suis totalement en phase avec les
associations celle que j'ai cité
d'autres qui aujourd'hui demandent à ce
qu'elles puissent faire leur travail
c'est à dire d'accueillir dans la
dignité des personnes qui sont
persécutés je le redis d'une manière ou
d'une autre est-ce qu'il faut accueillir
tous les migrants en france laurent
berger gérard collomb fait un distinguo
entre les réfugiés politiques et puis
les migrants économiques il dit nous
nous devons accueillir celles et ceux
qui sont victimes de la guerre mais nous
ne pouvons pas accueillir l'ensemble des
migrants économiques est-ce que ce
distinguo vous semble porter que demeure
une politique d'asile c'est extrêmement
important et il faut le faire je le dis
d'asile des réfugiés politiques et ça
c'est très bien et il faut raccourcir
les délais faire que ce soit plus rapide
etc mais je crois qu'il faut il n'est
pas question réfute l'argument terre en
disant ben ça veut dire que c'est les
naïfs qui pensent qu'il faut accueillir
toute la misère du monde etc je vous
rappelle que pendant la campagne
présidentielle le président de la
république il est allé en allemagne et
il a dit félicitations madame merkel
pour l'accueil de réfugiés bien plus
nombreux que ceux qui sont présents
aujourd'hui en france
et aujourd'hui je défie quiconque de
dire qu'il y à un afflux à ce point
massif que nous serions incapables
d'avoir au minimum au minimum il
politique d'accueil digne après je crois
pas que ça suffira à résoudre le
problème mais cela il faut l'accompagner
d'une politique d'une réflexion
migratoire est ce qu'on peut se poser
deux mois allez je demande deux mois on
se pose pendant deux mois et on se dit
c'est quoi une politique migratoire
digne de ce nom dans notre pays et
quelles orientations européennes nous
demandons-nous la france on est capable
de le faire sur d'autres sujets s est
très bien à l'europe en termes de
politique migratoire là au contraire on
nous fait croire que parce qu'on serait
dur avec les faibles ceux qui sont là
aujourd'hui eh bien on les en
empêcherait d'autres de venir ça ne
marchera pas parce que même ce qu'on le
fait subir aujourd'hui c'est
malheureusement moins pires que ce
qu'ils subissent de là où ils partent
quand on vous entend depuis tout à
l'heure laurent berger on a l'impression
d'entendre un homme politique est ce que
c'est le rôle d'un syndicaliste de
parler comme vous le faite j'avais la
cfdt à travers l'histoire elle a été
souvent critiquée par quels procédés
mesure des positions audacieuses qui
était un peu transgressives pour le
syndicalisme il ya un point sur laquelle
sur lesquels la cfdt n'a jamais transigé
c'est la question des valeurs qui nous
ont fait toujours soutenir nos camarades
dans les pays opprimés que ce soit des
dictatures fascistes des dictatures
communistes qui ont fait que sur tous
les terrains ce qui a compté pour nous
c'est la dignité humaine et le respect
des plus fragiles et des personnes en
difficulté est là dessus la cfdt et
continuera dire ce qu'elle pense vous
savez en termes purement cynique je pas
sûr que ça nous rapporte de l'audience
auprès des salariés je sais pas si ça
nous ont fait perdre ne souhaite pas
mais ce que je sais c'est que la cfdt
quand elle pense que les droits
fondamentaux sont attaqués peu importe
ce que ça lui coûte elle le dénonce
alors justement cette question des
valeurs et des droits fondamentaux c'est
ce qui a fait réagir la commission
européenne hier à propos de la pologne
elle a déclenché une procédure inédite
contre varsovie accusé de viol et l'état
de droit avec sa réforme judiciaire une
procédure qui peut entraîner de lourdes
sanctions elle a bien fait la commission
repos puis je crois que le rôle de la
commission européenne justement c'est de
rappeler les valeurs qui prédomine
notamment en termes d'indépendance de la
justice en europe et je crois que il y à
des dérives on le sait des dérives
populistes dans un certain nombre de
pays qui sont en jeu aujourd'hui pour
l'autre pour les démocraties et donc je
crois que le rôle de l'europe qui si
elle veut préserver son modèle un modèle
qui est un modèle démocratique un modèle
2 tentation de réduction des inégalités
même si elles sont encore trop
nombreuses et bien elle doit agir et moi
j'attends ça de l'europe
l'autriche en début de semaine le
nouveau chancelier qui est chrétien
démocrate a fait une coalition avec
l'extrême droite
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire et surtout union européenne est
resté plutôt silencieux aux autres par
rapport à cet événement politique est-ce
qu'elle a bien fait ou est ce que au
contraire vous auriez préféré qu'elle
réagisse d'abord ça m'inspire beaucoup
de craintes et puis ça m'inspire aussi
le souhait que dans les pays où sont au
pouvoir
des majorités qui ne sont pas d'extrême
droite ou qui sont pas populiste que ça
réussisse et c'est aussi pour ça que la
cfdt entend dire ce que sont les
conditions d'une réussite d'une
politique mener une politique
démocratique qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec tout donc ça m'inspire ça d'abord
ça m'inspire qu'il ya un risque
aujourd'hui de l'extrême droite en
europe extrêmement fort et pas on n'en
n'a pas fini nous avec ça la france n'a
pas fini il y avait plus de 30 % de
personnes qui ont estimé que finalement
marine le pen aura qu être président de
la république même si et s'était planté
entre les deux tours d'eau font débat
donc on n'en n'a pas fini donc il faut
être vigilant justement à pour écouter
ce que sont les ressorts de ceux de ce
vote deuxièmement je crois que l'europe
est elle respecte le vote même alors
elle en est un peu contrainte mais je
constate c'est que oui il ya 15 ans mais
justement car en
effet c'est parce qu' un certain nombre
d'idées de valeur commencent à pénétrer
et encore ce qu on commença à avoir
moins là d'ignacio moins fréquente c'est
quoi c'est la réalisation et de
l'extrême droite oui d'une certaine
manière mais c'est aussi l'indignation
en fréquente regarder ça c'est pâques en
europe en autriche il n'y avait
malheureusement que quelques milliers de
personnes pour condamner la présence de
l'extrême droite à des postes clés dans
le gouvernement et donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on soit vigilant
de façon quotidienne sur ces problèmes
là c'est le cas en europe la
confédération européenne des syndicats
fait extrêmement attention aux droits
fondamentaux dans ces pays là dans les
pays qui sont aujourd'hui gouvernée par
des majorités populistes ou d'extrême
droite
en tout cas où l'extrême droite est
présent mais c'est un combat qu'il faut
qu'il faut continuer de mener et c'est
un combat sur les idées les valeurs et
on revient au sujet précédent dernière
question rapidement sur ce thème ce
temps là justement le super je vous
l'avais évoquer brièvement parlant de la
france de cette politique migratoire
justement est ce qu'il faut surtout
qu'elles soient européennes s il
faudrait pas que ce soit le chantier
prioritaire sont pour l'instant elle
délaisse un peu ce champ est que chaque
pays se retrouvent à se débrouiller oui
vous avez raison on l'a bien vu dans les
dents dans les années précédentes quand
c'était des italiens qui géraient leurs
problèmes et les grecs voilà on a laissé
faire et on n'a pas forcément répondu à
leur appel en disant ça serait bien
qu'au niveau européen on y travaille
donc oui c'est un sujet européen
il faut revenir sur un certain nombre de
règles qui sont obsolètes notamment la
règle de dublin qui fait qu'on doit
revenir dans le pays où on est rentrés
enfin c est donc tout ça ça mérite une
vraie politique européenne alors après
moi je dis pas que c'est facile vous
savez que j'ai pas le discours facile je
dis pas que pour le président de la
république ou pour n'importe qui d'autre
c'est facile d'arriver en europe et puis
de dire il suffit yakafocon non parce
que les majorités dans un certain nombre
de pays sont quand même ultra
conservatrices sur ce sujet mais c'est
la seule voie possible c'est le seul
passage possible pour avoir une
politique migratoire qui soient humaines
et qu'ils soient nous non pas naïve mais
qui soit quand même accueillante qui est
quand même un peu le devoir de l'europe
laurent berger on va passer à la
deuxième partie de cette émission est la
question de vos rapports avec l'exécutif
[Musique]
vous êtes à la tête d'un syndicat qui se
veut réformiste l'ambition du président
de la république c'est de transformer le
pays vous sembliez donc être le
partenaire naturel pourquoi le courant
ne passe pas entre vous emmanuel macron
moi je dirais pas qu'ils passent pas le
courant d'abord humainement il passe
comme il doit se passer entre en jeu à
la bonne distance entre un responsable
syndical est il présent de la république
j'irai pas qu'il ne passe pas mais je
crois que il ya il ya une petite
conception du pouvoir qui parfois laisse
penser qu'on pourrait se passer des
corps intermédiaires quand la cfdt
construit sa vision de la démocratie sur
une articulation entre la démocratie
politique et démocratie sociale et donc
il ya quelques réglages qui ont étonné
qu'ils ont été nécessaires on l'est on
est en train de les opérer c'est à dire
on s'explique moi je suis franc s'est
jamais été autrement que francs mais je
crois qu'il faut comprendre qu'il n'ya
pas de transformation possible dans
notre pays si on met pas la société en
mouvement et que la société se met en
mouvement
notamment parce qu'il ya des corps
intermédiaires et des arrêts sont
syndicales des associations etc et
deuxièmement le monde de demain
certains l'ont pensé
et la cfdt en fait partie nous nous
avons travaillé sur les transformations
numérique l'impact du digital sur le
travail la transition écologique et donc
je crois qu'il faut faire avec ce qu'on
a envie de travailler et qui ont
réfléchi on n'est pas les seuls y'en a
plein d'autres moi je demande pas ni de
place de partenaire privilégié parce que
c'est pas du tout confortable et on l'a
jamais souhaité ni de prendre toutes les
idées de la cfdt mais en tout cas un
dépistage est passé ça en tout cas pas
de considérer non les choses ont bougé
objectivement sur la formation
professionnelle il ya eu négociation sur
l'assurance chômage les négociations on
va travailler sur l'avenir de la des
finalités de l'entreprise ce que doit
être l'entreprise s'était donc il ya des
choses mais oui il faut se caler mais ce
n'est pas totalement anormal au début de
son début de quinquennat mais ça vaut
personnalités finalement vos rapports
étaient notoirement bon avec françois
hollande est ce que il deviennent par
notoirement mauvais avec emmanuel macron
et non pas du tout non non non non non
ils sont pas mauvais du tout avec avec
emmanuel macron ils sont ré so c'est moi
j'ai un avantage par rapport peut-être à
beaucoup d'autres c'est que je connais
je n'étais pas du tout impliqué
politiquement j'ai jamais été impliqué
politiquement et je connais mes
interlocuteurs que parce que je suis à
cette responsabilité d'ailleurs le jour
où je serai plus je ferai autre chose et
j'aurai d'autres interlocuteurs
d'enlever une activité professionnelle
parce que dans ma vie quotidienne ne
sont pas mes interviews pamiers mais a
minimisé demi et donc moi je la cfdt se
positionne en toute indépendance et je
le dis c'est juste je ne pense pas et je
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent qu'il
faut que ce gouvernement réussisse pas
parce que j'ai un intérêt partisan parce
que s'il réussit pas regarder le risque
comme on en vient on ne vient de
l'évoquer de l'extrême droite mais pour
qu'il réussisse il faut qu'il fasse avec
avec la société dans sa complexité dans
ce qu'elle représente est donc l écoute
qu'ils écoutent les corps intermédiaires
ayant précisément ce que vous avez
l'impression de n'être pas suffisamment
vous cfdt écouter ce que votre robe ce
n'est pas moins important contre x par
exemple soukaina fou non aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui on peut interpeller sur un
certain nombre de sujets on a dit ce
qu'on pensait sur l'assurance chômage on
pousse le fait que l'on aura interroge
les finalités de l'entreprise et des
réflexions sont menées là-dessus moi
j'ai pas de mauvaises relations avec les
uns ou les autres et elles sont elles
sont correctes mais je mets et j'ai j'ai
mis quelques alertes c'est vrai ces
derniers temps en disant attention
attention tout ne se décidera pas d'en
haut ça peut pas être techno jacobins et
centralisée justement on vous sent dans
la tente face à emmanuel macron et
pendant ce temps là sa cote de
popularité elle remonte remonte c'est
quelque chose d'assez surprenant
d'ailleurs il à inverser la courbe est
ce que c'est palestine que finalement
les français ils adhèrent à la forme et
au fond et à la manière dont ça se passe
en dépit du fait que vous aimeriez
qu'ils vous parlent plus et qu'il vous
écoute plus mais d'abord je
je le redis j'ai pas le sentiment qu'on
n'ait pas écouté je donne juste des
alertes c'est il ya les premiers mois et
puis ensuite il ya forcément un peu plus
de difficulté qui arrivent et dans ces
cas là dans une société a besoin de
régulation et de corps intermédiaires
pour faire aussi de la régulation mais
tant mieux enfin la cote de popularité
si ça moi ça m'occupe assez peu
personnellement parce que je pense que
ça peut être lié à tel ou tel événement
comme par exemple décès de johnny
hallyday ou vous savez je ne sais pas du
tout
je ne sais pas parce que des fois ça
tombe des fois ça remonte moi je me
réjouis que je ne souhaite pas que les
politiques soient mal aimé dans notre
pays je souhaite pas que ceux qui
gouvernent soit soit sans arrêt sous la
défiance dehors de nos concitoyens je
trouverai je trouve pas ça
particulièrement sain c'est difficile la
tâche de ceux qui gouvernent aujourd'hui
est difficile la tâche des responsables
d'organisations patronales ou syndicale
est difficile parce qu'il ya des choix à
faire parce qu'il ya des du courage à
avoir moi je ne souhaite pas que on
considère que ces gens là ce sont des
gens qui sont encore aux équipes n'ont
donc tant mieux si il est il et il est
apprécié mais c'est ça ça dit rien n'est
fini dit ce qu'il dit
l'objectif d'une politique l'objectif
d'un homme politique l'objectif d'un
syndicaliste c'est pas d'être aimé et
son objectif c'est de transformer dans
la justice et et c'est ça qu'on lui
demande est ce que ce n'est pas la
méthode jupitérienne verticale que vous
dénoncez qui finalement est apprécié des
français est-ce que vous avez des
français ils sont totalement paradoxaux
comme chacun d'entre nous c'est à dire
qu'on attend beaucoup de l'homme ou la
femme providentiel et en même temps on
voudrait qu'on soit davantage écouté
individuellement c'est à dire que ça
c'est ça c'est vieux comme le monde et
ça restera bientôt trancher dans le vif
oui mais toutes les études montrent que
de plus en plus ses salariés en ce qui
nous concerne mais aussi les citoyens
dans la société en général on veut la
voir davantage de prise sur les choix
qui les concerne donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut le dire est que ces créations de
mode victoria mais vous savez la
consécration je suis à ce rouge revient
dans deux mois il aura baissé et vous me
demanderez de lapider parce que il aura
baissé nos c qui est important c'est la
cause la politique menée et qu' il y ait
des grandes directions que les promesses
soient tenues je crois que c'est
important parce qu'il ya une attente
autour de ça mais très clairement que ça
se fasse en intégrant que les citoyens
ont besoin d'avoir de la prise sur les
choix qui les concernent question donc
il faut redonner des marges de manoeuvre
plus large sur le syndicalisme laurent
berger emmanuel macron avec son arrivée
au pouvoir entraîner une recomposition
politique est ce qu on a aussi assisté à
une recomposition syndicale cette année
cette année on a assisté à l'arrivée de
la cfdt comme première fois comme
première organisation syndicale
c'est quand même un événement historique
ce n'était pas le cas depuis 1895 ça
n'avait jamais été finalement le classer
quoi la victoire du syndicalisme
réformiste sur scène dans les qualifs
mais qui assume de regarder le réel tel
qu'il est moi je raconte pas d'histoires
ça me plaît ou ça me plait pas la
situation mais enfin folle et des
travailleurs ils n'ont pas besoin qu'on
leur montre et qu'on leur dise que tout
va mal parce que ça nous arrangerait ou
que tout va bien parce que ça nous
arrangerait aussi donc regarder la
réalité telle qu'elle est obtenir des
résultats assumée qui est des compromis
que tout n'est pas facile et puis
finalement un syndicalisme qui qui évite
la posture pour être sur le fond des
sujets qui fait des propositions donc
c'est un événement important en 2017
c'était pour antérieure à l'élection du
président de la république mais ça a
quand même été un événement social
important cette année est ce que les
syndicats ont encore un avenir selon
vous est ce qu'ils peuvent encore peser
aujourd'hui oui ils peuvent encore posé
pesé mais il faut sans doute qu'ils
s'interrogent sur leur façon de
travailler leur façon d'être utile aux
travailleurs c'est ce que la cfdt a
commencé moi je je l' ai dit à plusieurs
reprises le syndicalisme est mortel
comme l'ensemble des institutions et
pour qu'ils ne meurent pas parce qu'on
aura toujours besoin de rééquilibrer
rééquilibrer le pouvoir pour les en
faveur des travailleurs dans le monde du
travail pour qu'il ne meurt pas il faut
être utile aux salariés leur apporter
des services leur obtenir des résultats
et avoir une parole de vérité vous dites
c'est ce que la cgt a commencé à faire
les autres ne l'ont pas fait c'est déjà
assez difficile de gouverner la cfdt je
m'occupe de la cfdt les autres en tout
cas ce que ce dont je m'aperçois c'est
que dans les résultats aux élections
professionnelles la cfdt progresse et
elle progresse d'autant plus lorsqu'elle
n'a pu obtenir des désaccords dans les
entreprises qui améliorent la vie au
travail les conditions de travail les
salaires
la protection sociale monsieur bergé
justement pour parler de méthodes là
vous étiez face à vous êtes face à des
grosses réformes et l'exécutif a choisi
une méthode bien spécifiques elle
négocie à chaque fois avec un syndicat
en face d'elle syndicat par syndicat
quoi va accepter aussi cette méthode
dans la négociation sur des six corps au
dossier est ce que ça vous a pas plomber
un peu pour vous affirmer affirmez vos
positions mais elle a fait ça sur les
ordonnances maintenant les la méthode
des pucelles la wii mais on a fait ça
que sont les ordonnances beaucoup sur
les ordonnances a été un échec ou et
vous n'avez pas réussi à mobiliser dans
la rue et donc la même année mais on n'a
pas voulu mobiliser dans la rue c'était
pas m'énerver mais ne me faites pas
porter des chèques d'autres la cfdt n'a
pas appelé à manifester elle n'a pas
appelé à manifester pourquoi parce que
tout simplement on voulait pas faire
cette démonstration de faiblesse
qu'aurait peut-être est-il utile
d'ailleurs pour le gouvernement pour
montrer que les syndicats étaient un
truc d'avant-hier ou d'hier nous on n'a
pas fait ce choix là on était en
désaccord sur un certain nombre de
contenus des ordonnances et en accord
sur d'autres le fait de renvoyer à
négociations entreprises par exemple est
une bonne chose pour nous mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait des dispositions
comme la fusion des irp et où une
décision in à terra des employeurs dans
les moins de 20 qui n'étaient pas
acceptables mais la cfdt maintenant elle
a décidé de sang de s'engager sur ces
ordonnances dans les entreprises auprès
des travailleurs pour mettre en place
les instances de dialogue social pour
mettre en place les actions qui vont
bien sûr les conditions de travail les
salaires etc et donc tout c'est
la méthode de concertation elle était
contestable il y en avait eu d'autres
précédemment c'était conférence sociale
ça convenait pas à tout le monde il y en
a qui préfèrent des réunions bilatérales
mais aujourd'hui on assure la formation
professionnelle une négociation avec les
organisations d'employeurs pareil sur
l'assurance-chômage
avance on va revenir sur tous ces
dossiers sur tous ces dossiers dans la
troisième partie pour revenir sur ce que
vous disiez ce que la faiblesse de la
mobilisation syndicale finalement elle
n'a pas donné des arguments ceux qui
jugent les syndicats dépasser mais où
c'est le rapport de force pour une
organisation syndicale c'est évidemment
d'être capable de temps en temps d'aller
dans la rue si elles l'estiment
nécessaire mais c'est aussi la capacité
de faire des propositions qui sont
retenus et qui ont du sens c'est ce que
la cfdt est capable de faire sur tout un
tas de sujets c'est son nombre
d'adhérents c'est le nombre de voix
qu'elle obtient dans les élections
professionnelles et là dessus l'année
2010 est pour la cfdt plus tôt d'année
la porteuse donc c'est l'annus
horribilis que vous voudriez faire dire
grosso modo depuis tout à l'heure qu'en
fait ils font sans nous moi je passe mon
temps à discuter sur un certain nombre
de sujets pour que pour que les choses
avancent sur l'assurance-chômage
avant-hier sur l'entreprise aujourd'hui
et c'est donc on travaille sur les
fonctions publiques pour défendre la
situation des fonctionnaires hier donc
moi j'ai des rencontres avec ses
interlocuteurs on travaille je ne
demande pas ce qu'ils appelent à des
routes les propositions de la cfdt mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'on veut à
chaque fois nous on juge sur pièces en
fonction du résultat est ce que c'est
utile ou non aux travailleurs vous
parliez du nombre d'adhérents la france
reste le pays de l'union européenne où
il ya le plus faible taux de
syndicalisation
pourquoi vous n'arrivez à convaincre
parce que je crois que le syndicalisme
souffre d'une image qui est un peu
caricatural
si je peux me permettre l'image ou en
gros syndicaliste c'est quelqu'un qui
est derrière une banderole qui râlent et
qui est pas content ce qu'il ya c'est le
cas tous les jours dans les entreprises
ya des hommes et des femmes qui font un
travail extraordinaire dans la
discussion dans les négociations et
qu'aucun des avancées pour leurs
travailleurs ou c'est même le fmi dit
que là où il ya une organisation
syndicale les inégalités sont beaucoup
plus ou moins fortes que là où il n'y a
pas d'organisation syndicale c'est à
dire que et d'ailleurs toutes les études
le montrent là où il ya une présence
syndicale les salariés valides cette
présence par une confiance importante
auprès des heures sur les syndicats et
là on n'est pas présent évidemment on
considère qu'on sert à rien de sa faune
n'y est pas donc je crois qu'il y aille
à changer l'image des syndicats et que
nous mêmes nous avons à développer
davantage de services comme ça peut être
le cas dans d'autres pays européens à
destination des salariés et des
adhérents c'est ce qu'ont fait par
exemple nous avec un système un service
qui s'appelle réponse à la carte où nos
adhérents peuvent téléphoner est mise en
relation avec une personne physique dans
leur territoire sur les questions de
formation de parcours professionnel de
salaire pour répondre à leurs problèmes
laurent berger on a l'impression que le
front syndical ne sera plus unis quelles
sont aujourd'hui vos rapports avec
philippe martinez de la cgt et jean
claude mailly de force ouvrière ils sont
cordiaux
d'abord il faut cordiaux et amicaux avec
avec les deux c'est à dire on n'a pas de
problème de humains entre nous c'est
déjà une bonne chose
ensuite je crois qu'effectivement il ya
une forme de distance qui est prise
aujourd'hui avec la cgt qui est ni de
son fait ni du mien qui est simplement
que nous ne sommes pas sur les mêmes
logiques syndical en série mondiale non
c'est jamais irrémédiable vous savez il
y en a qui l'on peut théoriser l'ailé
droite les gauchers les jeunes c'est
quoi irréconciliables c'est faux faut se
méfier de ça c'est jamais irrémédiable
je sais pas sur certains sujets on est
capable de s'exprimer en commun on s'est
exprimée en commun sur la question
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
on va s'exprimer en commun sur la
question en demandant une concertation
sur les travail sur les travailleurs en
situation de handicap donc on est
capable de faire des choses en commun
mais c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas la même
vision et stratégie syndicale et avec
jean claude mailly chacun sait qu'on a
travaillé ensemble pendant l'été on
s'est aussi vu avec philippe martinez
plusieurs fois pendant l'été et puis ben
lorsqu on peut travailler ensemble on
poursuit un travail en commun lorsque
c'est pas possible eh bien non
faut pas tenter de peser plus oui mais
où c'est semarang dans notre pays on
trouve normal qu'il y ait cinq six sept
huit partis politiques 12 13 14 15 le
média d'information différents mais par
contre il faudrait un syndicat pourquoi
il ya des divers il ya des sculptures
syndicales différentes il y a deux
grands courants je pense qu'on pourrait
réduire le nombre d'organisations
syndicales dont chacune dans chacun de
ces courants mais c'est normal qu'ils
aient des courants syndicaux différents
alors après la question de l'opposition
un syndicales se pose aussi la question
de l'opposition politique nous avons
posé la question aux français avec notre
partenaire opinionway diriez vous que
l'opposition politique au gouvernement
et audible et regardez ce qu'ils ont
répondu 70% des personnes interrogées
ont répondu non est-ce que c'est aussi
votre avis oui c'est plutôt mon avis oui
pour la faute là qui est ce que jean luc
mélenchon y est pour quelque chose est
ce qu'il a contribué à l'échec de
l'opposition réforme du gouvernement ou
c'est moi je suis dit non l'opposition
et la majorité donc c'est plus facile
pour pour bois d'une certaine manière
parce que moi je suis juste dans le
parti de ceux qui veulent que le monde
du travail soit écoutée respectée
le ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des pans entiers de courant qui
existait qu ont disparu ou qui sont en
recomposition et du coup il ya
effectivement les oppositions qui sont
les plus audibles c'est finalement les
oppositions des et aux deux extrêmes il
est extrêmement mélenchon vous dites que
les deux extrêmes ce mélenchon vous
casser mon vote ne sais pas si vous
regardez le
l'assemblée nationale en tout cas il est
plutôt de ce côté là de l'assemblée
quand on l'a on l'entend en tout cas
entendue tenir des propos très durs
envers les syndicats est ce que
finalement n'a pas de diviser les
syndicats au lieu de vous aider à non il
nous a pas dit viser parce qu'on était
en désaccord sur l'appréciation sur le
fait même de travailler sont dans les
concertations nous n'étions avec force
ouvrière et d'autres pour aller dans les
concertations parce que et c'est là où
on peut être utile et faire des
propositions mais aussi contre et des
mauvaises idées il y en avait quelques
unes qu'on a contré mais vous et moi
j'ai pas de leçon à recevoir de
quiconque je me mêle pas de politique
alors monsieur mélenchon qu'il ne mette
se mêle pas de syndicat et je ne vois
pas en quoi il pourrait s autoproclamer
porte parole des travailleurs pas plus
lui que n'importe lequel vous l'avez
donneurs de leçons ces derniers temps
bah moi si vous voulez quand on est
interpellé publiquement et c'est la
première fois je réponds quand on est
interpellé publiquement expliquant qu'il
ya qu'à faut qu'on les leaders syndicaux
devraient faire ça ça ça mais au nom de
quoi monsieur mélenchon peut parler au
nom des huit cent mille adhérents de la
cfdt et me dire ce que je devrais faire
donc ça franchement ça glisse en ce qui
me concerne j'ai su pas tellement
sensible j'y suis pas psy ni choquer ni
ni agacé mais bon au bout d'un moment il
faut stopper quoi je veux dire c'est
qu'il se taise comme l'a dit jean claude
mailly
j'aime pas à dire ça à quelqu'un parce
que moi je souhaite que tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer bon en tout cas qui
nous donne qu'il ne nous donne pas de
leçons en tout cas ça ça aura pas
beaucoup d'effet on va passer à la
troisième partie de cette émission
laurent berger vous en avait déjà parlé
mais on va a détaillé les réformes
nombreuses d'emmanuel macro
[Musique]
est-ce que selon vous laurent berger ces
réformes engagées par emmanuel macron à
elle menace le modèle social français
pas forcément non pas tout
moi je traite l'autre mais lesquels si
vous voulez ce qui si on prend les
ordonnances puisque ce sont ceux sont
les seuls finalement on connaît le
contour aujourd'hui sur le code du
travail leur envoie des gosses et son
entreprise obligatoire pour bouger les
règles du travail dans toutes les
organisations dans toutes les
entreprises de plus de 50 ça sera avec
les organisations syndicales c'est
plutôt quelque chose d'intelligent qui
nous fait aller vers un système de
dialogue social beaucoup plus affirmée
la housse est là la vraie vie des
travailleurs finalement qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont les lieux de travail et là on se
rapproche de modèles qu'on peut parfois
envier à nos collègues nordiques ou
autre quand il est question de décider
dans les entreprises de moins de 20 que
le patron pourra tout seul décider
l'adaptation des règles du travail qui
sont celles de la branche fiche de la
branche vous fixé encore du travail là
j'ai dit oui ça met en cause le principe
de
le modèle social en tout cas un certain
nombre de règles de total qui sont
extrêmement importants donc je moi je le
modèle social faudrait définir ce que
c'est ces deux mots en ce qui me
concerne la capacité à donner des droits
individuels aux personnes dans un cadre
collectif c'est-à-dire un système de
solidarité et de protéger les
travailleurs à l'égard de dans le
rapport de fin dans le rapport de
subordination qu'ils ont vis-à-vis de
leur employeur et ça ça se fait par le
dialogue social de mon point de vue donc
il ya des points positifs il ya des
points négatifs étiez vous que cette
réforme donne plus de place aux salariés
est ce que pour vous le pari est réussi
c'est une occasion non c'est une
occasion manquée sur ceux de mais là
c'est vous dire c'est une occasion
manquée à 2 1 2 point de vue le premier
s'est
on nous dit on va renvoyer à la
négociation d'entreprise très bien mais
par contre sauf pour l'organisation des
instances représentatives du personnel
là on va en faire une pour tout le monde
là même une seule c'est paradoxal c'est
quasi schizophrénique c'est à dire qu'en
gros on dit ban le faisons en fonction
de la réalité de chaque entreprise pour
l'organisation du travail de temps de
travail etc mais par contre sur
l'organisation des instances
représentatives du personnel tout le
monde pareil et d'ailleurs ça à m ça va
mettre en situation difficile un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui souhaitent
avoir des représentants de proximité etc
à des chsct
donc ça c'est un premier problème le
deuxième c'est que on avait
l'opportunité de redéfinir ce qu'est une
entreprise à travers ces ordonnances
finalement et en disant on veut
davantage de négociations renvoyait
davantage de négociations d'entreprise
parce qu'une entreprise c'est une forme
de propriété sociale c'est une forme de
c'est une communauté de travail ou la
place du travail doit être valorisée à
même hauteur que la place du capital ça
n'a pas été fait alors vous savez dans
ces cas-là il ya deux axes de postures
syndicales et de se dire ça n'a pas été
fait c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible c'est terrible et puis de jouer
perdant ou alors il ya de repartir à
l'attaqué comme on souhaite le faire
nous sur le projet entreprise qui est
prévue en début d'année on va en parler
mais on va d'abord écouter le président
de la république est revenu sur cette
réforme du code du travail c'était
dimanche soir donc on entretien accordé
à laurent delahousse et pour lui il
faudra attendre deux ans avant que cette
réforme
on écoute cette réforme produira des
résultats dans les fréquents dans les
deux ans les cinq ans dans les cinq ans
mais après moi je dis il faut attendre
deux ans pour qu elle et qu'elle
commence à avoir ses pleins effets mais
je suis pas là pour faire des pronostics
jeu là pour agir laurent berger il
faudra attendre deux ans oui c'est ça je
voudrais savoir c'est quoi les pleins
effets attendus de cette réforme si
c'est le renforcement du dialogue social
alors là il faudra attendre d'ici deux
ans on verra si les entreprises ont
plutôt fait le choix de dialoguer
davantage avec les représentants du
personnel pour pour améliorer leur
performance économique et social si
c'est la création d'emplois je dis que
c'est pas une réforme comme ça qui crée
de l'emploi mais du coup pour vous ça
c'est très fort mais les plier ou durant
ces deux ans vous espérez encore faire
bouger les lignes à l'intérieur des
entrepreneurs à l'intérieur des
entreprises c'est tout commence cette
réforme tout commence en fait c'est
maintenant que ça commence c'est pour
savoir comment va s'organiser le
dialogue social sur quels sujets on va
débattre comment on va respecter la
représentation syndicale dans les
entreprises et il y aura de tout et
quels sont vos de marge de manoeuvre
concrètes en tant que syndicat
dans un certain nombre d'entreprises de
représentants ils vont commencer
lorsqu'on va vouloir l'employeur à
vouloir négocier sur tel ou tel sujet
pour en entreprise plus agiles ils vont
commencer par dire mais quid d'un accord
de dialogue social on fait quoi comment
vous concevez la place des représentants
du personnel dans l'entreprise et donc
il y aura des endroits où ça se passera
bien et les endroits ça se passera mal
et d'autres finalement un peu comme
avant ces ordonnances ya pas de ya pas
de solution miracle mais par contre
cette réforme elle n'a pas on soit elle
ne porte pas la possibilité de créer des
emplois c'est le vieux mythe parce qu'il
ya une partie de ces ordonnances qui en
fait est basé sur un mythe c'est pour
embaucher plus facilement il faut
licencier plus facilement et là je vous
fiche mon billet que ça ça ne marchera
pas
ça ne marchera pas parce que ça n'a
jamais marché et donc moi je crois que
c'est pas en terme cette réforme est là
pour capacité de donner plus d'agilité
aux entreprises soit on le fait
intelligemment par dialogue social et
dans ce cas on aurait beau résultat
comme on a eu 1 renault a esté x
ailleurs un certain nombre d'entreprises
parce qu'on a signé des accords qui vont
dans ce sens soit elle sera inutilisés
elle restera finalement lettre morte ce
serait dommage mais ce serait comme ça
peut en berger la prochaine grande
réforme celle de l'apprentissage de
l'assurance chômage et de la formation
professionnelle
vous en êtes où des concertations
sur la formation professionnelle la
négociation se poursuit elles avancent
l'idée pour nous il est de donner des
droits renforcés à la formation
notamment pour les salariés qui en sont
le plus éloignés aujourd'hui dont on
sait qu'il suffit pas de donner des
droits aux personnes pour qu'elles
utilisent donc les demandeurs d'emploi
les jeunes les salariés des toutes
petites entreprises les salariés les
moins qualifiés et puis l'autre volet
c'est de dire il faut que ça se sache
offre de la certification il faut que ce
soit reconnue c'est pas juste pour pour
occuper un passé que ce soit reconnu
dans un parcours professionnel et
surtout le troisième volet c'est qu'on
accompagne les demandeurs de l'ailé les
salariés demandeurs d'emploi dans ce
parcours de formation donc tout ce
conseil en évolution professionnelle
qu'on veut faire fructifier
c'est à dire que cet accompagnement des
personnes à utiliser leur droit ça
avance plutôt bien mais
vous savez c'est très interactif une
négociation entre les organisations
syndicales et patronales c'est à dire
qu'il ya des moments où ça avance puis à
un moment où stagne on a attaqué en
termes de dates qui est fixé mi février
on y arrivera oui on y arrivera oui
alors justement on appelait ça ne fait
que s'enchaîner pour vous ces réformes
ces sondes et vraiment des très grosses
réformes est ce que finalement celle ci
qui s'ajoute aux précédentes
ces négociations qui s'enchaînent est ce
que ça vous le percevez pas comme une
stratégie d'épuisement de la part de
l'exécutif
pas forcément mais de toute façon ils
peuvent essayer y arriverons pas je vous
le dis parce que moi j'entends ce qu'ils
disent et on n'a pas le temps de travail
etc attendez on parle de quoi et par
d'emploi assurance chômage ce qu'on
parle de formation professionnelle on
parle d'apprentissage on parle de
conception de l'entreprise on parle des
négociations qui vient d'être lancée sur
la fonction encadrement ou
l'encadrement tout c'est quand on est
une organisation syndicale si on n'a pas
travaillé sur ces sujets il faut aller à
la plage faut faire autre chose nous ça
fait longtemps qu'on travaille sur ces
sujets là qu'on a des propositions à
faire donc oui c'est dans ce parce que
park par contre se rajoutent des
réunions donc il faut y participer il
faut faire des propositions il faut
faire des contre-propositions donc c'est
dense mais la cfdt se sent pas du tout à
6 et 1 point du tout laurent berger sur
les contrats courent le gouvernement
veut les limites est ce que pour vous un
accord avec le patronat il possible sur
ce point là du coup c'est plutôt une
question à poser au patronat parce que
pour nous c'est plutôt possible d'aller
là on démarre sur l'assurance chômage
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que le premier
pas avait pied avait été mis dans la
porte en 2013 avec une taxation même
légère des contrats courts maintenant on
le voit les contrats courts de moins
d'un mois explose donc il faut
responsabiliser quant à 114 emplois il
faut exprimer il faut que les
entreprises assument leurs
responsabilités parmi ses
responsabilités il ya le fait de rendre
plus cher le recours à un contrat court
et très court que à un contrat en cdi et
donc nous nous avons fait une
proposition de cotisation dégressive à
l'assurance-chômage une cotisation plus
élevé les premiers jours les premiers
mois du concret du contrat pour ensuite
aller à une cotisation qui serait qu'il
serait plus basse sur la formation
professionnelle charlotte sur la
formation professionnelle justement vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement mais on a le
sentiment que l'exécutif vous le dites
veut privilégier la formation des
chômeurs éloignés de l'emploi des
chômeurs de longue durée notamment pour
les faire informés vers des métiers dits
d'avenir aussi des métiers finalement en
demande donc est-ce que c'est pas un peu
inversés le principe de base et se dire
on va former des gens pour répondre aux
demandes du marché ça vous dérange parce
que normalement la formation s'est
plutôt fait pour permettre aux gens de
faire ce qu'il veut c'est donner vous
savez la formation s'est donné la
possibilité aux gens de s'intégrer dans
un parcours professionnel mais c'est pas
totalement illogique quand même que sur
un territoire sur une filière on parle
des besoins pour regarder quelle quelle
formation pourrait on pourrait mener ce
qui n'est pas logique c'est d'avoir une
pure logique d'être sûrement seulement
sur une logique adéquat sioniste à dire
un métier à un emploi et une formation
pour occuper cet emploi mais qui me
permettraient pas d'occuper d'autres
emplois derrière mais objectivement
disons disons le le risque numéro un
c'est aujourd'hui de pas trouver les
compétences sur un certain nombre de
métiers ce serait quand même totalement
paradoxal dans un pays qui a un taux de
chômage comme le nôtre et donc il faut
partir c'est ce qu'on propose aussi dans
la négociation formation professionnelle
mais aussi d'en apprendre sur
l'apprentissage des besoins dans les
territoires et dans les branches parce
que moi ce que je demande au patron
c'est à dire bon ok vous pleuré beaucoup
sur eux on trouve pas de compétences etc
c'est réel dans un certain nombre de cas
et nous qui comme enfin comment quel
poste pour combien de temps vous avez
besoin et regardons comment l'appareil
de formation peut mettre peut se mettre
en mouvement sur ce sujet là donc moi je
suis ni totalement adéquat sony je ne
suis pas du tout mais je suis pas non
plus sur faisons des formations
complètement en dehors des besoins
économiques l'intérêt c'est quand même
le retour à l'emploi vous parliez
d'apprentissage mignola le pique nique
au pardon apparaît de a souhaité une
révolution copernicienne vous avez
l'impression qu'on va prendre
branchement sur cette réforme c'est
assez tendues entre le gouvernement et
les conseils régionaux
moi je crois que sur cette réforme
pourquoi s est tordu mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui la responsabilité ce sont
les conseils régionaux sur
l'apprentissage et là l'idée c'est de
donner à 100% aux branches je ne sais
pas demandez pas à 100% c'est pas une
bonne chose mais région c'est une bonne
chose c'est une bonne chose de confier à
un certain aux branches des
responsabilités accrues pour les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer sur la
correspondance avec les besoins en
compétences dans les filières mais sur
un certain nombre de secteurs je crois
qu'il faut une compétence régionale pour
une raison simple c'est que l'ouverture
des cfa par exemple ça correspond aussi
à des enjeux d'aménagement du territoire
et d'aménager des enjeux d'emplois de
proximité par exemple dans l'artisanat
dont on sait qu'ils sont eux pour le
coup ils jouent le jeu de
l'apprentissage donc je pense qu'il ya
une mesure à trouver y compris équilibre
se sont agrandies qu'on est passé aux
grandes régions ça reste le bon échelon
oui ça reste ça peut rester pour serge
je vais vous le dire nous on est pas
tous au branchement n'est pas tout
régions non plus mais je crois qu'il
faut il faut laisser en partie une
compétence apprentissage aux régions
notamment sur les branches qui auront du
mal à avoir une logique une logique
nationale en termes d'apprentissage et
au risque d'avoir un regroupement des
cfa seulement dans les grosses
agglomérations ce serait catastrophique
on va parler du smic laurent berger le
smic qui sera revalorisé de 1 24 % au
1er janvier prochain sans coup de pouce
toujours avec notre partenaire
noël nous avons demandé aux français
s'ils jugé cette hausse suffisante ou
insuffisante et ils sont 64% on va le
voir à la trouvait insuffisante
le smic augmenté sans coup de pouce vous
le regrettez
moi ce que je regrette je vais vous dire
franchement c'est qu'on parle des cartes
des rémunérations seulement au moins du
smic est donc le smic revalorisé indexé
sur l'évolution du coût de la vie je
trouve ça absolument nécessaire ce qui a
été le cas après ce que je trouve
scandaleux c'est qu'on se satisfassent
dans notre pays que le suffixe un
salaire auquel les gens pendant toute
leur vie parfois
seulement droit et pas à une évolution
de carrière parce que si vous regardez
bien avec cette hausse du smic on va
rattraper le bas de grille encore un peu
plus de bacs gris des conventions
collectives et ce qui est scandaleux
c'est qu'on réfléchisse pas et que le
patronat ne s'engagent pas davantage sur
l'évolution des bacs gris qui
permettrait que le smic c'est quoi c'est
un salaire minimum d'entrée dans
d'entrer dans l'emploi pour des gens pas
qualifié et quand on a travaillé deux
ans trois ans quatre ans et qu'on reste
au smic on est plus en entrée demandé au
patron une vraie politique de dynamique
salariale bien sûr une politique
salariale dynamique et une évolution des
bacs gris comme on dit c'est à dire des
d'abord que ça commence pas en dessous
du smic il y en a encore quelques-uns et
surtout qu' il soit beaucoup plus
dynamiques en bas de grille qu'ils ne le
sont aujourd'hui mais pourquoi c'est
comme ça parce que ils se réfugient
derrière le débat national sur le smic
et puis comme les exonérations
de vos entreprises concerne plutôt les
bas salaires eh bien on joue on joue on
joue comme ça donc le smic c'est on doit
pas y rester toute sa vie et il est
normal qu'ils soient indexés pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de perte de pouvoir d'achat
mais on peut pas satisfaire que de plus
en plus de salariés soient payés au smic
et pendant des durées très longues
justement un groupe d'experts en plus de
sa préconisé une réforme du mode de
calcul du smic disons qu'il fallait
revoir éventuellement la double
indexation voir le bc qu'est ce que vous
en dites dans le b c le bc c'est pas
possible vous savez pas ce que le smic
c'est à 2 manière de l'appréhender ya la
manière macroéconomiques
qui est de dire il faut pas que ça
empêche les gens d'accéder à l'emploi
parce que le salaire voilà et puis à la
manière micro c'est à dire la vie des
gens et la capacité à vivre avec un smic
ou pas et là y compris les gens du
groupe d'experts ils se sont davantage
basée sur le respect macro que l'aspect
micro c'est à dire comment on vit et on
a entendu dire parfois dix ans oui mais
si on le désindexer si on le baisser un
peu on pourrait être compensée par la
prime pour l'emploi mais vous rendez
compte ce que ça veut dire en termes de
dignité ça qu'on vit de son travail lui
on n'a pas besoin quand on travaille
d'avoir un système comme la prime pour
l'emploi alors c'est important qu'elles
existent mais on veut d'abord vivre de
son travail et donc il faut continuer de
l'indexer on peut revoir les mécanismes
d'indexation je vais dire moi je suis
pas dans les tabous absolue mais il faut
continuer que le smic évolue en fonction
est réel ce cas l'évolution d'une minute
fonction publique emmanuel macron
souhaite une différenciation du point
d'indicé entre les trois fonctions
publiques est ce que c'est une
discussion qui est possible où vous
dites cette mini rouge non nous on tient
à l'unicité des trois fonctions
publiques y compris pour le point à 10
mais surtout on tient à des évolutions
de carrières et des rémunérations le
précédent gouvernement avait acté un
plan dévolu sur des carrières et des
rémunérations ou dans lequel il y avait
eu négociations la cgt s'est engagé
d'autre aussi et ce gouvernement a
décidé de le freiner f1 ne pas
l'appliquer pour 2018 il a appliqué pour
2017 mais pas pour 2018 moi je demande à
monsieur du soft et je demande à ce
gouvernement d'appliquer ces ppcr comme
on dit c'est le sigle en 2018 et je
demande que cesse cesse enfin ce
discours stigmatisant l'égard des
fonctionnaires c'est c'est dramatique
pour le service public mais c'est
dramatique aussi pour la cohésion
sociale merci beaucoup merci laurent
berger d'avoir été l'invité de cette
dernière émission de l'année de
l'épreuve de vérité vous retrouverez à
michel grossiord à partir du 8 janvier
puisque désormais l'épreuve de vérité ce
sera le lundi toujours à 18h merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis en attendant
très bonnes fêtes à tous sur public
sénat
[Musique]